la tour eiffel est une grande coquette
elle ne peut pas dissimulé son âge mais
elle cache ses aventures bien avant
l'eurovision en 1945 une équipe
d'alpinistes avaient escaladé sans
tambour ni trompette dans la plus pure
tradition des montagnards réalisant
ainsi la véritable première de ce sommet
parisien
ils étaient trois deux garçons et une
fille dont on a depuis longtemps oublié
les noms
il convainc jusqu'au troisième étage
dans un temps record c'était en décembre
c'était donc aussi une première
hivernale
ce fut peut-être celui ci qui pris le
plus de risques
mais que dire de l'extraordinaire numéro
réalisé quelques années plus tard par
onze gold sans filet sans assurance
aucune à 200 mètres au dessus du sol
11 gold une nature qui n'avaient pas
horreur du vide